sea levels are rising the oceans have
been pushing higher at a greater rate
year after year due to melting ice and
the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change estimates they could rise by
another meter or more by the end of this
century research has predicted that the
Arctic may experience ice-free summers
as soon as 2050 if all the Earth's land
ice were to melt our oceans would rise
216 feet so what would this mean for
Asia's coastlines just three feet of
added sea level would eliminate up to
14,000 square feet of the Indian
subcontinent so rise of 70 times that
would be disastrous for the region
Mumbai and Calcutta would be underwater
along with the entire country of
Bangladesh which is home to 160 million
people the coast of Southeast Asia and
the surrounding islands would be pushed
inland drowning Bangkok Ho Chi Minh City
Singapore Manila and Hong Kong land
that's currently home to 600 million
Chinese will disappear underwater wiping
out Shanghai and Beijing sea levels in
Japan will rise 10 to 20 percent faster
than the global average after all is
said and done hundreds of millions of
people will be forced to retreat inland
leaving behind the continents largest
and most prosperous cities to be buried
by the ocean